avec un peu plus de 100000 habitants de
la circonscription d'avalon bonnaire est
la moins peuplée de l'yonne
la majorité veut valent elles s'étendent
de migennes jusqu'au bout en vendée car
et des pompes en passant par avallon
tonnerre ou encore saigner seignelay et
son école à la pointe du numérique
c'est ici que jean yves collet a décidé
d'y faire campagne ce matin à le député
sortante vient de démontrer qu'il est
possible d'habiter la campagne et
d'avoir comme ses élèves les mêmes
chances de réussite quand même élu aux
dernières législatives sous l'étiquette
ps il est désormais investi par le parti
des manuels macron mais veut dépasser
les clivages
le principal c'est de faire avancer
l'économie c'est ça quand même
la lutte contre le chômage zéro offres
d'emplois non pourvus dans nos
territoires
l'école pour tous l'accès aux formations
tout au long de la vie ce sont des
projets qui dépassent les clivages et
avec mon expérience et mes convictions
je veux apporter ça à mon pays dans un
cadre réconcilier qui est celui de la
république en marche sur sa route le
député sortante trouvera donc engrais
vie libre et investi par la droite et le
centre
le président du département a longtemps
hésité avant de se porter candidat il a
crispé certains jusqu'à son propre camp
mais tout cela semble maintenant
derrière nous sur cette terre ici à
vézelay comme partout dans la
circonscription il veut porter le fer
contre jean yves caullet qui l'accusent
de tromper l'opinion et les électeurs
celui qu'on a pas vu sur le territoire
et qui réapparaît rénové donc vierge de
toute action politique passée alors que
pendant cinq ans eh bien il a participé
à ce que la france soit dans l'état dans
lequel elle est aujourd'hui donc il
devra sur la place publique sur le
terrain démocratique rendre des compte
de cela edwige jacques est la candidate
du front national
la jeune femme se présente pour la
première fois à une élection dans
l'yonne
elle habite le nord du département et
travail en ile-de-france forte du score
de marine le pen et ses quelques 46 % au
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
sur cette circonscription
elle vise jacques et croit en ses
chances et s'estime tout aussi légitime
que ses adversaires sur ce territoire
moi déjà ça fait 17 ans que j'ai rejoint
l'yonne
a la base je suis quand même
bourguignonne puisque moi je suis de la
nièvre
je connais mon patrimoine ayant de la
famille aussi dans l'avallonnais
je connais quand même le secteur réunion
de travail pour philippe robert sa
suppléante
on aurait dit deux camps le candidat du
parti de jean luc mélenchon reçoit et
travaille chez lui dans la campagne
avallonnaise agriculteur ancien porte
parole de la confédération paysanne et
ex soutien de montebourg à la primaire
du ps il ne voit ni favori ni candidats
se détachent et il renvoie dos à dos 20
yves collet et andré villiers ça va être
compliqué pour tout le monde je pense je
pense que pour tous les candidats
fusse-t-il présenté comme étant les
favoris dire leur bilan soit comme
gestionnaire de la collectivité
départementale avec toutes les
difficultés aujourd'hui qui a soit en
tant que député il faudra aussi que l'un
et l'autre présentent leurs bilans
vis-à-vis des citoyens
la prime aux sortants et les faits
macron vont-ils jouer pour jean yves
caullet le front national va-t-il
continuer de surfer sur ses bons scores
élection après élection de la lionne
andré villiers réussira-t-il à se
qualifier pour le second tour aux
électeurs de décider les 11 et 18 juin
prochains et douze autres candidats sur
cette circonscription mehdi barbeau
christophe la mode hier françois
meyroune anita carrasco à nice cannes il
lia frédéric back au biac joël rigolât
cyril ray coquet nicolas robert naudi
roi guillaume durand et dorsaux usta